yep coronavirus definitely is not
initiating something like my mom and I
have been doing every day's that we go
outside to feed the locals because you
know I've never seen this in Jerusalem
it's amazing birds coming from all over
the place you know even Paris green
parish that I've never seen in my life
[Music]
hi my name is Nick and I've been living
in Vietnam for the past two years and
this is also what I found myself during
the corona outbreak honestly I have
nothing but positives to share about the
Vietnamese government they have dealt
with the whole situation extremely well
the whole country went into lockdown
within a very short period period of
time since the news broke over the
coronavirus I think in February they
closed all the borders and the schools
and the businesses and everything and
yeah we only had 270 cases and we are
now three weeks case free and out of
lockdown - super super positive hi i'm
stefano and i'm Manisha and this is
Francois he's ready for us it's been a
bit difficult especially with the baby
because my family hasn't been able to
visit and they've been missing out on a
lot of milestones and his life hi I'm
Jack Sarah and the president of Bethlem
barber college where I work in Bethlehem
but I also live in Jerusalem and during
these days we have lived during hard
times like the covered 19 pandemic going
back and forth to work has not been easy
you know I between commuting between
Jerusalem where I live and
then coming to Palestine Bethlehem where
it's really there is a lot of
checkpoints like this one that is here
so there is an army sitting right and
left and if they suspect a car they
don't allow it going they don't want to
have more cases of their covet 19
thankfully there was no trouble usually
they stopped me and they asked me a lot
of questions I'm Jojo and I am currently
in Kathmandu Nepal I came to Nepal
shortly before the lockdown happened to
visit my mom who actually lives here and
then the lockdown hit and I'm still here
so it's now after 10 a.m. and I am
walking to the one supermarket that is
allowed to stay open after 10 a.m. in
Nepal basic provision shops fruit and
veg sellers and pharmacies are allowed
to be open between 6 a.m. and 10 a.m. so
that's when most of the people out and
about and shopping I'm very fortunate
that my walk to the supermarket goes
right past lotus stupa which is a
religious site in my neighborhood
zyne hamza they're supposed to be in
school
wakey-wakey now I am preparing to attend
an online session I think the online
sessions are boring and what's funny
about this is that my mom is giving the
session and she's right next to it
actually one of my students is my son we
prepared this to separate between my
classes and
my son's glasses mom is giving a glass
MJ is taking the same class I am sitting
with the same baby baby I flew back home
to Greece three weeks ago and I've been
in quarantine since then I'm in the
middle of writing my dissertation and
revising for exams our exams are online
our graduation has been postponed and
I'm not sure how I'm gonna be able to go
back to DOM and get my things before my
rent runs out
even though Greece has a big cafe
culture people are still visiting cafes
the tables and chairs are stacked
outside and people are just standing in
parking lots and in open air and areas
talking to each other while drinking
their takeaway coffees this is the way
that most Greeks have started
socializing with each other after over a
month of lockdown
hi guys I'm Stefano and I am a chef in a
local restaurant here a witness coming
before the quarantine my life was pretty
busy after I had a little time mines and
I had to invent my own base there for
now
[Music]
I used to travel a lot with journalists
all around Yemen and outside but now we
have looked out inside the house now
there are two cases here in sauna and
people are not still aware about how
dangerous this viruses they don't know
the danger of this panel my country is
suffering from five years war now after
this war we have so many sicknesses and
people are suffering from malnutrition
from Colorado from death Iria what can
we do if corona virus will spread all
around my country so we're currently at
campo de marte which is a medical
facility here in Lucca hopefully they
both let us
[Music]
so it's a bit tricky when leaving the
house with a newborn because they
obviously can't wear the mask like us so
instead I put bleach it's kind of over
his shoulder so now we're finished with
the appointment my husband wasn't able
to go into the appointment with me again
he had to wait outside in the waiting
room so that's just one of the things
that's been a bit difficult with Kovac
19 you know you want both parents to be
present on all the important occasions
doctor's appointments and everything
instead we find ourselves like recording
the appointments for each other so we
can hear what's going on the airport is
completely shut there are no flights in
or out of the country which means that I
am here until the airport opens up again
I was planning on moving to New York
about in about ten weeks but of course
that's not happening anymore
I actually just started an online
schooling program right before all of
this craziness happened so for me being
forced to stay indoors has also forced
me to become more productive and really
focus on on getting this qualification
basically this is how we get to leave
our house as long as you are all alone
you can take it off if you have a car
with an even plate number and even an
even license plate you can drive it on
even dates and those with license plates
they get to drive it on an odd date so
basically I'm going to the pharmacy to
get some stuff for the family this is
how I have to this is the only way I can
walk into the pharmacy and only one
person at a time can walk in home is
giving a class in this room and Hamzah
is taking class in this one the big
challenge for English teachers during
Hogtown was that all the schools in
Vietnam have been closed in January so
for four months
no school schools were open and actually
was extra challenging because there's
this notion going on in did not
westerners drop her own
to hit that which is not technically
true the most cases of coronavirus are
Vietnamese people coming back from China
Korea or Europe all the Vietnamese
people start being scared of foreigners
we go outside to get some groceries and
people would actually run away from us
or there will be mild racism when they
are shouting go back to your country or
somebody would pass you in a motorbike
and they could spit on you so yeah some
racism towards westerns was definitely
challenging me and Mama Selma sitting on
the balcony enjoying the peace of the
night but you know one of the cool
things about covered 19 I've seen in
nature something that I haven't seen in
my life if you could see I mean here the
whole area I mean has been really
amazing birds coming from all over the
place great parish that I've never seen
in my life are inhabiting this trees
like hundreds of them benefits because
of the coronavirus thing or things and
things got easier and quieter and we can
see them more and more migrating and
coming to our area